In this lesson we will talk about
distributed hash tables, which enable a form of
content overlay called a structured overlay. We'll
talk about a particular distributed hash table called
Chord and an underlying mechanism that enables
it, called consistent hashing. Chord is a scalable,
distributed lookup service. A lookup service is
simply any service that maps keys to values.
Examples of lookup services on the internet include
DNS and directory services. Chord has some desirable
properties, including scalability, provable correctness, and reasonably good
performance that's also fairly easy to reason about.